مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفاق
[موسيقى]
امبارح النصر عمل ريمونتادا على الشباب
ونجح بانه يفوز علي بثلاثيه مقابل هدفين
ورونالدو طبعا سجل الهدف الثالث ولكن بعد
تسجيل الهدف شفنا رونالدو عم يعمل تصرف
ربما مستغرب انه نزل على الارض وكانه يسجد
فصار الحديث نورنالدو سجد او هناك سجود
رونالدو هل هو اسلم ولا هل تغير شيء خلال
وجوده بالسعوديه القصه انه بعد ما سجل
الهدف وصار او صارت عمليه الاحتفال هاي
اللي هي كانت يعني غريبه شوي لاعبين النصر
صاروا يصفقوا لرونالدو وهون صارت التكهنات
تكثر عن انه ربما يكون قد حدث تغير بوجود
رونالدو بالسعوديه والحقيقه انه رونالدو
خلال وجوده بالسعوديه تاثر بالثقافه
العربيه بشكل كبير على ما يبدو لانه
امبارح او اول مبارح كان ابنه رونالدو
جونيور او كريستيانو جونيور كما يسمى طالع
عم يحكي باللغه العربيه وعم بيقول كيف
حالك والحمد لله وعم يحكي حتى السعوديه
وبالتالي هذا الامر عمل تفاعل كبير ايضا
على تويتر شفنا كمان قبل اشهر كان في بنت
من بنات رونالدو عم تتعلم اللغه العربيه
واما بتعلمها اللغه العربيه وهذا امر ايضا
يشير الى انه ابناء رونالدو وعائلته
رونالدو وهو نفسه
تاثروا الى حد ما بالثقافه اللي موجوده
بالسعوديه
طيب شو التحليلات او شو الفرضيات اللي
موجوده لطريقه احتفال رونالدو هاي واحده
من الفرضيات المتداوله بشكل كبير انه
رونالدو شاف بعض اللاعبين العرب وشاف بعض
المنتخبات العربيه وشاف بعض الانديه
العربيه بتحتفل بهذا الشكل ولكن هو يعني
ربما لا يعرف معنى هذا الاحتفال او ربما
انه الموضوع مش من منطلق ديني سواه بل انه
المنطلق انه تقليد لبعض اللاعبين العرب
بنشوف محمد صلاح بيسجد بنشوف بمصر ايضا
يسمى منتخب الساجدين بعد كل هدف بصير في
سجود وكذلك الحال بالنسبه لكثير من اللعيب
العرب الفرضيه الثانيه انه في لاعبين
اوروبيين وغير مسلمين برا لما يسجلوا هدف
بينزلوا على شكل السجود وبيبوسوا ارضيه
الملعب بيقابلوا ارضيه الملعب تامنا منهم
او انه ربما يعني حاله من التفاؤل بانه
هاي العمليه بتخليهم او بتجيب لهم الحظ
خلال المباراه او ما الى ذلك وبالتالي هاي
التحليلات المتداوله بشكل كبير عن موضوع
سجود رونالدو ولكن حتى الان لم يصدر اي
شيء من النصر لم يصدر اي شيء من رونالدو
نفسه حتى انه الصوره نفسها المتداوله
والفيديو المتداول ما نشروا رونالدو عنده
على صفحه الانستقرام كذلك الحال بالنسبه
لصفحات النصر الرسميه ما نشرت اي شيء عن
هذا الامر وبالتالي بقي الموضوع موضوع
تداول على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي طيب شو
راح يصير على المدى البعيد بخصوص هذا
الاحتفال توقع الشخصي انه هذا الاحتفال
راح ينتشر بشكل كبير بعد ما رونالدو عملوا
بعض الهدف الثالث امام الشباب لانه
رونالدو هو متل ما بنعرف كلياتنا قدوه
لكثير من لاعبي كره القدم حول العالم
العرب وغير العرب المسلمين والمسيحيين
واليهود ومن كل الجنسيات والاديان
وبالتالي احتفاله اذا بتتذكروا احتفاله
بالسي المعروفه اصبح ترند بارك عالميه
وصار في كثير لاعبين يحاولوا يقلدوه
وبالتالي لما يعمل هذا هذا الاحتفال
بالدوري السعودي اكيد راح يصير في ايضا
محاوله تقليد لهذا الاحتفال هذا ببساطه
المتوقع طيب رونالدو خلال وجوده بالسعوديه
مثل ما حكينا هو مرتاح ولكن ايضا ظهرت بعض
التقارير الصحفيه التي تحدثت عن رغبته
بالرحيل عن النصر على ما يبدو حسب ما عم
نشوف على مدار الايام انه هاي الاخبار مش
كثير دقيقه لانه رونالدو على ما يبدو
منخرط بالمجتمع السعودي رونالدو سعيد في
السعوديه يقدم اداء جيد ولا يزال ينافس
على لقب الدوري مع الاتحاد ولذلك لحد الان
كونه ما في اي اخبار رسميه وما في اي
تسريبات الى حد ما موثوقه عن هذا الموضوع
خلينا نعتبر انه هذا الموضوع
بتصنيف الشائعات وبانه هو شيء مش رسمي ومش
اكيد حتى الان لانه رونالدو على ما يبدو
عايش فتره جيده مع نادي النصر السعودي هذا
كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم بعد الصافره حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل نكونوا بالف خير